I understand he just recorded an album
with Jack White yes cooking together you
didn't know it was not together it was
on his label Third Man Records is it is
all real we did this is real it stand up
it's not music or anything he what is he
doing there then he got me the show to
do the recording I gave him a CD at a
random burger place in Tennessee you
gave him a CD I was at I was at a burger
place in Nashville him and his friend
were sitting at a table one table over
and I gave them my seed I CD that I'd
just came out lately or were you covert
and like you know what I wasn't I you
said do you like stand-up and they were
like yeah and I go here's two CDs please
listen and tweet see did they just put
it on the stack of other CDs they handed
at that meal he just immediately throws
it oh thanks so much um I didn't know
what he did with it cuz I didn't hear
anything about it and then a year later
Reggie Watts was doing a show and he was
with Jack White and Reggie called me and
put jack on the phone and he was like
hey I liked your CD come and do an album
on my label in Nashville so I did that
that's great I hate how high that story
got so serious sorry you guys ever look
at but the moon in the mill that they're
like you know what's his deal that's if
I was like a hipster doing that joke
guys ever look at the moon it's like
what what's his job even
he controls the tides oh he controls the
tight you know
well he controls the tides Rory what do
you think would happen with all those
coffins if there wasn't a moon
controlling the tides that was so funny
I mean we didn't compute like we've
heard I don't mean to give are so funny
I forgot to laugh but that was literally
so funny that I was just kind of in awe
of the callback we have time for one
question when you die is it just lights
out great question
really great question um I don't know I
don't know I don't know what happens and
anyone that tells you that they do know
they're foolish yet because nobody knows
and I hate to get serious but this is
why I came on here nobody knows so why
pay that money for a plot in a cemetery
there's spending money now you don't
even know what happens save that money
put it in your wallet put it in your
pocket get buried with it what if you're
in heaven and you want to buy a coffee
your house oh well if you've passed that
on [ __ ] out a lot no different different
acronym